[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24
si la semana pasada les hablamos de las
vacunas esta semana tratamos otro de los
grandes cambios que trata este recién
estrenado 2021 el ver exit y sus
consecuencias en las en la práctica tras
cuatro años el divorcio consumado entre
reino unido y la unión europea ya está
ahí para ello me acompañan en este
estudio
luís rivas es director del canal
euronews bienvenido luis razia luz delia
ron athey y periodista independiente
especializada en economía bienvenida
delia
y desde londres en conexión nuestro
corresponsal juan carlos bejarano juan
carlos buenos días que quiero digas
carlos bray sit un divorcio consumado
hoy en primera plana
[Música]
pues cuatro años y medio de divorcio
largo y traumático el break shit ya es
una realidad en este estrenado 2021 y
sus primeras consecuencias comienzan a
verse carestía de algunos productos en
supermercados británicos aumento de los
trámites burocráticos y sobre todo
diferentes frustraciones que en el
futuro pueden hacer peligrar valga la
redundancia con la unidad del reino
unido desde una escocia que ha
abandonado a europa en contra de su
propia voluntad como a una irlanda del
norte que tendrá un estatus híbrido
hasta qué punto las consecuencias del
break shit real el que ya tenemos sobre
la mesa pueden resquebrajar los pilares
del reino unido es una de las cuestiones
que seguirán nos planteamos antes
repasamos algunas portadas jugué antes
nacional una frase a medias entre el
francés y el inglés adiós y buena suerte
con una caricatura simulando un salto al
vacío más optimista es el 'daily mail'
que califica de nuevo a amanecer la
rúbrica del break sheet coincidente con
la aprobación por cierto de la nona
nueva vacuna en el reino unido- y la
fotografía de un boris johnson historia
liberación bien de cuatro años y medio
después de aquel referéndum se consuma
esa salida del reino unido- de europa
bueno esto ha durado mucho ha sido más
traumático yo creo que de lo que
podríamos pensar hace cuatro años y
medio cuando se produjo a que el
referéndum que titular pondría en este
divorcio de cuatro años y medio louis yo
diría algo que ha sido ya utilizado en
la prensa ni vencedores ni vencidos ni
vencedores ni vencidos
delia yo iría por lo que el break si se
llegó vamos a la práctica porque este
2021 es el año de las consecuencias en
la práctica de lo que ya tenemos ahí en
que vamos a ver los ciudadanos las
consecuencias del bereshit en lo
inmediato luis bueno lo inmediato si
tenemos en cuenta que entran de nuevo
las funcionar las fronteras a partir de
octubre los ciudadanos europeos tendrán
que utilizar el visado y el pasaporte
para entrar en el reino unido también
hay consecuencias que son un periodo de
adaptación también hemos visto incluso
las anécdotas de los aduaneros
holandeses que
tenían que recuperar el sándwich de
camioneros británicos
vamos a ver consecuencias también en el
roaming telefónico vamos a ver
consecuencias en el precio de algunas
cosas y vamos a ver consecuencias
también mucho más directas que por
ejemplo en las becas erasmus que no
permitirán que los estudiantes
continentales vayan al reunido pero yo
creo que es un período de adaptación
esto lo más lo que más se ve ahora mismo
veremos también que tendrán que
adaptarse todas las cuestiones
burocráticas aunque digamos que yo creo
que las grandes líneas de lo que es lo
que se presentaba se han salvado quiere
decir va a continuar aún en comercios y
en tarifas aduaneras y sin cuotas que
era lo más importante y después todo el
resto es algo que estaba dentro de este
divorcio cuando hay un divorcio siempre
algunas consecuencias pero yo no creo
que sean tan graves como se vendían en
principio vamos a preguntarle a nuestro
corresponsal en londres juan carlos
hemos visto imágenes de supermercados
desabastecidos y al mismo tiempo un
primer ministro boris johnson que
intenta vender el break ship como un
triunfo en medio de la terrible ola de
la pandemia de coronavirus que está
viviendo
los momentos del país especialmente en
londres donde te encuentras cuáles son
las consecuencias de estos primeros días
de break sit bueno y carlos en estos
primeros días si se nota menos productos
europeos por ejemplo en frutas y
verduras pero realmente no tan
traumático como se esperaba por una
sencilla razón ya los supermercados se
estaban preparando precisamente para el
break sit y entonces lo que lo que
hicieron
antes del 31 de diciembre fue
precisamente almacenar más productos así
que sí aunque hay una disminución
todavía no se nota si están comenzando a
subir los precios y yo creo que lo que
lo que más ha llamado la atención es
precisamente lo del paso fronterizo con
el puerto de dover normalmente allí
pasan unos 6000 camiones al día en estos
momentos solamente están pasando unos
2000 y debemos decir que más o menos uno
de cada cinco tiene problemas
precisamente con todos estos trámites
aduaneros y tienen que regresarse o se
demoran más así que el verdadero impacto
incluso como lo dijo michael wolff que
fue
artífices del éxito el verdadero impacto
del desabastecimiento se va a comenzar a
notar quizás el próximo mes y de otro de
output boris johnson le sacó partido al
preside precisamente con el tema de la
vacuna al lograr que el reino unido
fuese el primer país en aprobar las
vacunas no solamente una sino ya tres
que se hayan comenzado a aplicar a
administrar y de hecho siempre que
escuchamos a boris johnson decir en este
momento reinó unido- ha vacunado más
ciudadanos que toda la unión europea
junta así que el verdadero impacto
todavía tenemos que esperar quizás al
próximo mes y es que sólo han
transcurrido dos semanas desde que se
hiciera efectiva la salida de reino
unido de la unión europea y varios
problemas saltan a la vista
el acuerdo in extremis salvo de
aranceles al flujo de bienes pero los
controles fronterizos y los trámites
burocráticos suponen costes extra para
muchos negocios
delia no sé si ésta es la principal
consecuencia en la práctica es decir
toda la carga burocrática yo creo que la
principal
causa que se está viendo en este momento
hay que tener en cuenta que debido a la
crisis sanitaria no hay no hay un real
flujo de personas no hay personas
viajando por cuestiones de turismo de
trabajo de estudios entonces por el
momento no se puede determinar qué tan
grande va a ser el impacto en este en
este tipo de sectores ahora el sector
burocrático se ve ese es el impacto más
grande en este momento hay que ver los
los meses por venir cómo se va a seguir
dando esta situación y qué os parece
como comentaba nuestro corresponsal juan
carlos bejarano en medio de esta
pandemia que está siendo tan virulenta
con londres como ha vendido entre
comillas vender el primer ministro boris
johnson el acuerdo del president medio
de esta crisis sanitaria louis
yo creo que le ha venido muy bien por
supuesto porque están en gran bretaña y
hablo bajo la autoridad de bejarano que
está allí se habla mucho más del cob y
de que de las consecuencias del break
sheet es decir el que tiene en cuenta
también que estamos hablando de las
primeras de las primeras consecuencias
pero yo insisto no son
son consecuencias de un poco de
adaptación pero no son verdaderamente la
catástrofe que se anunciaba y en este
sentido
johnson no puede cantar victoria pero sí
puede sentirse aliviado de que las cosas
vayan no sean tan negativas y por
supuesto la pandemia les salva un poco
de salir todos los días en primera
página hablando del albergue sin embargo
muchas de las nuevas limitaciones no se
aplicarán para irlanda del norte que
comparte frontera terrestre con la
república de irlanda país que sigue
perteneciendo a la unión europea irlanda
del norte no si podríamos decir del día
que sale ganando con el break sit y que
escocia es digamos la otra cara de la
moneda la gran perdedora creo que sería
un poco más tibia es decir que sale
ganando irlanda del norte yo diría que
no sale perdiendo en todo el caso porque
guarda ciertos privilegios de los países
que se encuentran en la unión europea
pero también hay ciertos a ciertas cosas
en contra por ejemplo los las mercancías
que llegan de parte del reino unido- van
a tener ciertos retrasos en lo que viene
a ser el borde que se ha puesto en el
mar
desde ya hay cierto desabastecimiento en
los supermercados tampoco es que lo
estén pasando sin ningún efecto
colateral escocia sin embargo está
sintiendo todo el efecto de la salida de
la unión europea' y yo creo que eso
también a futuro puede causar un
problema para el reino unido porque si
escocia hay que recordar que escocia no
estaba de acuerdo en el referéndum que
hubo de salir de la unión europea creo
que esa no es el mantenerse por un 62
por ciento es un éxito que ellos no
querían su praxis muy inglés vamos a
preguntarle a nuestro corresponsal a
juan carlos bejarano londres escocia
juan carlos pide a la unión europea que
deje digamos la luz encendida para su
regreso y se reaviva el independentismo
irlanda del norte mueve fronteras a raíz
del break city por ejemplo gibraltar
abre abre la verja y aparca a la
soberanía en favor de la economía hasta
qué punto quizá la pregunta hasta qué
punto el break sheet puede hacer
peligrar valga la redundancia la unidad
del reino unido
yo creo que no inmediatamente porque
estaba precisamente revisando las cifras
de el tema de la independencia en
escocia en este momento más o menos por
ciento de los escoceses se muestra a
favor de la independencia del reino
unido pero esto no es suficiente
realmente para ganar el referéndum
porque esta fue la misma cifra que
tuvimos más o menos en 2014 bien lo que
sí llama la atención es que precisamente
en 2014 la unión europea le ayudó al
gobierno de david cameron con el
referéndum al decirle a los escoceses si
se salen quizás no los vayamos a aceptar
en la unión europea tendrán que hacer
cola ahora esto sería un punto
precisamente a favor de escocia y del
partido nacionalista escocés snp pero
quizás no lo suficiente y en irlanda
tampoco es fuerte digamos la posibilidad
de que irlanda del norte se una con
en la república de irlanda también
estaba viendo las cifras y muestran que
en una reciente encuesta por ejemplo un
40 por ciento de los islandeses del
norte se consideran británicos sólo un
25 dice ser irlandés y otro 24 25% se
describe nada más como de irlanda del
norte así que yo creo que estos
movimientos de independencia en escocia
y en irlanda del norte todavía no tienen
la fuerza suficiente para lograr ese
objetivo que ha buscado por ejemplo el
partido nacionalista escocés trasladó la
pregunta a la mesa luís d´elía creen que
estas situaciones en escocia en irlanda
del norte en gibraltar todos ellos
votaron contra el break sheet pueden
debilitar en el futuro al reino unido yo
les creo que no que no aunque no es
tanto porque en primer lugar hay que
recordar bueno lo que ha dicho bejarano
está claro es que no hay una mayoría
como para decir
escocia en el segundo en la presión que
ahora mismo está haciendo extorsión y la
y el partido nacionalista es porque
tienen unas elecciones también en
escocia que tienen que vender este este
asunto en tercer lugar hay que recordar
que para que se celebre un nuevo
referéndum tiene que tener el permiso de
londres que esto tendría que tenerlo
claro también por ejemplo
independentistas de otras regiones como
en cataluña
en gran bretaña para celebrar un
referéndum tiene que ser legal y con el
permiso del gobierno de londres no se
puede hacer así en de manera autónoma y
sin el permiso vamos a hacer en este
punto una breve pausa y a la vuelta les
quiero proponer varios asuntos
relacionados con el break sí pero vamos
a mirar fuera del reino unido- y fuera
de la unión europea entre otros cómo va
a ser el futuro del reino unido en el
mundo a un mundo en el que al que llega
como principal novedad
joe biden a la casa blanca en este 2021
lo comentamos a vuelta de pausa
[Música]
la disputa ha ordenado que comience en
los próximos días una campaña de
vacunación masiva desde diciembre hemos
visto un despliegue de vacunas un poco
más lento de lo esperado sólo 5 de las
85 regiones rusas incluir a moscú tienen
bastantes vacunas para lanzar una amplia
campaña de vacunación en moscú y un poco
más de optimismo la vida en la capital
rusa podría volver a la normalidad en
mayor siempre y cuando la gente se
vacune lo ha dicho el alcalde de moscú
serguéi sobiánin
el gobierno ruso dice que ha vacunado ya
a más de un millón y medio de personas
pero distintos medios rusos disputan esa
cifra y la rebajan a 300.000 no sea
tiene más de 140 millones de habitantes
ya ese ritmo puede tardar años en
vacunar a su población pero también pasa
que los rusos siguen mayoritariamente
reacios a la vacuna el 60% de los
encuestados es contrario a ponerse la
frente a un 40% que están a favor sobre
todo por el miedo a los efectos
secundarios pero también por la falta de
información sobre los ensayos clínicos
de la vacuna
i
turquía empezado este jueves con la
campaña de vacunación que está siendo
masiva segura en el gobierno turco que
ha dado unos resultados de cerca de
medio millón de personas a la jornada
son todos ellos de momento personal
sanitario sin embargo esperan que en los
próximos días ya empiecen a vacunarse a
personas mayores de hecho los primeros
en vacunarse fueron el ministro de
sanidad y el propio presidente turco
recep tayyp erdogán una muestra dijeron
ellos mismos para intentar a hacer que
la gente turca se vacuna y acepte la
única vacuna que de momento ha llegado a
turquía esta es la vacuna china de
sinovac que ha demostrado en las últimas
semanas no ser tan efectiva como otras
para luchar contra el coronavirus como
son la vacuna alemana the fighter y la
americana de modernas esto ha provocado
muchas críticas por parte de algunos
sectores médicos turcos como el colegio
de médicos que ha criticado la falta de
transparencia del gobierno a la hora de
comprar sus vacunas y ha preguntado
porque turquía compró la vacuna china y
no otras sin embargo erdogán este jueves
se defendió y dijo que turquía está en
proceso de adquirir la vacuna alemana
que de hecho ha sido producida por
ciudadanos alemanes de origen turco
[Música]
el continente africano se encuentra
besando la segunda ola de la pandemia de
coronavirus que como en el resto del
mundo ha sido más pronunciada que la
primera el continente registra más de 3
millones de casos de infecciones y más
de la tercera parte se encuentran acá en
sudáfrica el gobierno sudafricano ha
recibido algunas críticas por sus
demoras en negociar la llegada de las
vacunas pero ha confirmado recientemente
que para finales de enero se recibirán
un millón de vacunas que vienen del
serum institute de la india los miembros
del personal de la salud serán los
primeros en recibir que estas dosis y
según el plan del ministerio de salud es
que para finales de año el 67 por ciento
de la población sudafricana haya sido
vacunada logrando así la llamada
inmunidad de rebaño
a nivel continental la unión africana ha
confirmado la reserva de 270 millones de
vacunas para todo el continente y hay
países como kenia por ejemplo que ya han
reservado 20 millones de estas dosis
pero que ni ha presentado también un
evento importante en los últimos días y
es la aparición de lo que parece ser una
nueva variante del virus en ese momento
los científicos se encuentran
investigando qué tan graves pueden ser
las implicaciones de esta nueva mutación
[Música]
seguimos aquí en primera plana de radio
francia internacional y de france 24
esta semana analizando las consecuencias
reales de un break sheet que ya es una
realidad en este 2021 lo hacemos con mis
compañeros periodistas luís rivas de la
runa tegui y desde londres nuestro
corresponsal juan carlos bejarano uno de
los puntos que más costaron para sacar
el tratado a finales de diciembre que
evitó un break si duro fue la pesca del
día porque ha sido tan complejo el
sector de la pesca en este acuerdo in
extremis entre reino unido y la unión
europea yo creo que lo que hay que tener
en cuenta que el sector la pesca no
representa económicamente algo muy
importante para el reino unido
solamente el 0.1 por ciento de su pib
pero lo que sí representa es este
un símbolo político el estatus de perdón
de soberanía yo creo que eso también ha
sido el caballito de batalla de boris
johnson en el momento de su campaña para
salir como primer ministro
él siempre habló de la soberanía
marítima entonces tenía que defender
este este punto con capa y espada yo
creo que eso también éste le puso una
presión especial a este punto porque lo
que ellos reclamaban era el 80 por
ciento de las tres casas que se
realizaban en el territorio marítimo del
reino unido finalmente se ha llegado a
un acuerdo mucho más flexible es decir
este cinco años y medio de posibilidad
que la unión europea siga pescando en el
territorio marítimo del reino unido- y
después se va a negociar año por año las
cuotas que promete también ser bastante
empezado burocráticamente el 25 por
ciento al final se ha quedado que es una
victoria para la unión europea ahí los
pescadores dicen los pescadores vitales
que dicen que johnson les ha dejado
tirados
es muy difícil cumplir con lo que yo te
pedía eso lo referido a la pesca pero
hay otros sectores en reino unido
especialmente inquietos por esta era
post break city su futuro uno de ellos
el financiero el de la city de londres
juan carlos bejarano londres cuéntanos
por qué hay riesgo de pérdida de
actividad en este sector clave de reino
unido que mueve unos 204 mil millones de
dólares cada año
claro que sí pero quería contar algo
primero precisamente en estos momentos
carlos los más afectados con la salida
del reino unido de la unión europea son
precisamente los pescadores sobre todo
los de escocia que están teniendo
problemas para exportar a europa
precisamente porque todo el papeleo de
aduanas son los más afectados en este
momento y vamos con el tema del distrito
financiero por supuesto esto va a ser un
golpe para el distrito financiero pero
no va a ser el fin de londres de la city
como la capital de europa tengamos en
cuenta que en el siglo 17 la city ya era
la capital o por lo menos el distrito
financiero de europa y ya lo que
hicieron muchas empresas
de servicios por supuesto los bancos es
que abrieron sucursales en otros lugares
de europa ya se habían preparado queda
en todo caso por negociar en londres y
bruselas precisamente todo el tema de
competición o de competencia legal si va
a tener un impacto pero en la opinión
por lo menos de los expertos de los
economistas de los conocedores del
distrito financiero es que londres the
city seguirá siendo la capital
financiera de europa porque ya tiene una
infraestructura de hace muchos años muy
importante y el sector de servicios
recordemos para reino unido es muy
importante este es uno de los pocos
países del mundo donde el sector de
servicios es más importante por ejemplo
que el de exportaciones permítanme la
metáfora hasta ahora hemos hablado del
divorcio del break city y a partir de
ahora vamos a hablar de la búsqueda de
nuevas parejas tanto de ambos lados de
la parte del reino unido- de la parte
europea si me permiten un poco la
metáfora luís europa puede transformar
todo este divorcio traumático en una
oportunidad a partir de ahora
crecer y mirar al futuro yo creo que
desde bruselas se ha vendido la idea de
que la pelea por el break city y la
solución al break sheet ha sido un
ejemplo de la cohesión europea yo creo
que no es para tanto yo creo que eran 27
contra 1 y no era muy difícil que
estuvieran todos de acuerdo porque todos
defendían los intereses comunes
una vez que el ver si se ha dejado de
lado que era más que nada una
preocupación negociadora en dolor de
cabeza los problemas para la umh europea
van a seguir para seguir en el año que
viene en el futuro es decir los
problemas no eran tanto el vrac sheet
como para dejarlo es una negociación
pero los problemas con europea será su
enfrentamiento y su falta de unidad
con respecto a asuntos como turquía
asuntos internos también como el reparto
de las ayudas para después del cob y
como también el problema de la
emigración
por la unión europea se deja un dolor de
cabeza aparte que ha sido muy importante
de cuatro años pero esto no es no se
pone para en mi opinión un éxito como en
europea en sí
en el aspecto del éxito lo cierto ser
bueno 47 años de reino unido en europa
ahora sí quizás ya podemos ir haciendo
un balance del día de este periodo en
los cimientos del break si te está
también la percepción que tuvo siempre
reinó unido- de mirar a europa quizá con
un mercado exclusivamente con un grupo
de socios económico puro y duro y nunca
como un proyecto político no a partir de
ahí esa percepción estaba ahí no en lo
que ha sido este divorcio exactamente
nunca se planteó el concepto de unidad
europea fue es un tema más que nada
económico entonces este el reino unido
siempre estuviera dentro de la unión
europea y un pie afuera yo creo que por
eso siempre hubo tantas disputas y
pedidos de exclusión mismo no entrar a
la moneda del euro entonces yo creo que
al final cuando hubieron las crisis
económicas dentro de la unión europea
debilitó la razón primordial que ellos
tenían de ser parte y al final solamente
quedó las llamas la amargura
la amargura y por eso el divorcio tan
tan tan tan duro
porque una pregunta que yo me planteo
ahora es visto lo visto que hemos visto
en estos cuatro años y medio louis que
el discurso respecto al ver ex y tendrán
ahora los otros partidos euroescépticos
que hay en otros puntos de europa por
ejemplo lo hemos visto aquí en francia
con marín le pen que ha cambiado el
discurso en estos años respecto a la
unión europea antes era muy flexible y
ahora ya no ya ya ya vamos vamos
modelando en otros sitios hay
consecuencias respecto a estos cuatro
años y medio de ver éxitos no sí pero no
es no es igual en todos los países
porque y es por eso que bruselas intenta
también durante estos cuatro años y
ahora vender esta idea de que ha sido
que poner las cosas muy negras si
alguien quiere salir de la unión europea
pero como el sector miento no como miren
el argumento hay un punto que es muy
importante para los para los partidarios
del presidente de soberanía la soberanía
es sobre todo hay una cosa que se
plantea en todos los países porque
incluso en francia aunque se haya
cambiado
no hay mucha gente que no comprende cómo
se puede la jurisdicción puede estar
bajo un tribunal de justicia europeo es
algo que es rechazado en muchos países
no solamente en francia aunque el miedo
a salir de sobre todo el miedo económico
a salir de la unión pero hay aspectos
como la soberanía como el tribunal de
justicia europeo que muchos consideran
que no tiene por qué ser superior a la
legislación nacional son muy importantes
para muchos europeos también y a todo
esto reino unido se interroga por su
plaza en el mundo también con la
perspectiva de la llegada de joe biden
al poder en eeuu quien percibe a boris
johnson como un heredero populista de
donald trump juan carlos bejarano
londres como serán a partir de ahora las
alianzas internacionales de londres
bueno por el caso de eeuu podemos decir
que boris johnson ya comenzó a
desmarcarse precisamente de donald trump
que era su amigo y su aliado y dándole
la bienvenida a joe biden yo creo que
esa relación entre el rey no inhibe los
estados unidos que ellos consideran
especial
aunque se verá afectada seguirá siendo
importante porque sin duda alguna el
principal aliado de eeuu en europa es el
reino unido- y yo creo que esa relación
no se va a acabar es simplemente
cuestión de como reacomodarse como
estamos viendo y por supuesto el reino
unido pues siempre habla de su relación
que tiene con los países de la
mancomunidad británica de naciones y de
nuevos gigantes por ejemplo como india
sin duda alguna el reino unido ha salido
rápidamente incluso en sudamérica a
buscar nuevas alianzas comerciales
porque ellos consideran que ya tienen
esa independencia para realizar este
tipo de tratados comerciales sin que
tengan que pedirle permiso a bruselas
así que en ese aspecto yo no lo veo
antes negativo y hacia dónde mirará el
reino unido en esas alianzas
internacionales en la era post break
sheet es interesante porque realmente
las relaciones con la unión europea no
son las menos tensas con eeuu de ahora
la administración
bardem tampoco
un poco peor hay bastante fricciones
diplomáticas entre los dos países es
cierto que por el momento no hay un
socio natural que esté que provoque un
acercamiento mayor las nuevas potencias
pues puede ser india o algunos países de
américa latina pero va a ser un inicio
un poco un poco difícil y más en este
contexto de pandemia y crisis económica
global
louis palmer así que recordar que que
gran bretaña ya ha firmado más de 60
acuerdos comerciales con 60 países
en relación con eeuu yo creo que va a
ser el gobierno de obama 3 y en ese
sentido hay que recordar que obama está
siempre defendió la neuro pea y fue
contra el albergue porque es por sus
intereses a ellos les conviene negociar
de una de un golpe con 27 y no 27 golpes
y para otro lado hay que tener en cuenta
que la influencia de washington también
en irlanda recordamos la anécdota de
cuando a la bbc le pregunta a joe biden
él responde yo soy irlandés a eeuu
siempre dijo que el acuerdo de stormont
de la en irlanda al norte no se tocaba y
eso es algo muy importante también para
tenerlo en cuenta desde londres y desde
ya puso mucha presión para que eso no se
tocase pero hay que tener también en
cuenta que el 47 por ciento de las
exportaciones del reino unido- vienen
directamente a la unión europea es un
socio casi mayoritario después para
acomodar esas exportaciones a otros
cuatro polos comerciales
va a ser difícil otra anécdota muy
significativa no sé si lo han visto
mientras el primer ministro británico
boris johnson se preparaba para celebrar
su objetivo cumplido de sacar al reino
unido del euro
su padre es tan y johnson andaba
preparando todos los papeles para lograr
la nacionalidad francesa y proclama a
los cuatro vientos su sentir europeo el
padre de boris johnson no sé si quizá
simboliza a la inversa lo que le pasa a
muchos británicos digo a la inversa
porque suelen ser los hijos y las
generaciones jóvenes los pro europeístas
los ingleses de cierta edad los breakers
no y en este caso en el caso de la
familia johnson ha sido al revés
es una familia de privilegiado que decir
no hacer lo mismo para el resto de grant
británicos y al revés no va haber éxodo
tampoco de europeos que viven en el
reino unido hacia hacia el continente ya
se ha demostrado que más de tres
millones ya han pedido el permiso para
quedarse el problema va a ser para las
próximas generaciones para los
estudiantes que hacían su erasmo en
inglaterra que ya no van a obtener esa
oportunidad también era un intercambio
cultural los ingleses que venían por
ejemplo a francia y los franceses que
iban a inglaterra para estudiar para
tener el idioma un poco más adquirido
esas ventajas por el momento se
terminara trabajar porque para para
emigrar para allá ahora mismo hay una
serie de puntos de puntos con un mínimo
de salario también en contra de un
mínimo
y eso va a ser mucho más en fin responde
a los intereses de la gente nacional que
no quería que denunciaba que los
extranjeros iban a ocupar su puesto de
trabajo como pasó aquí en francia con el
famoso fontanero polaco totalmente pues
me quedo sin tipo para más ha sido un
placer compartir estos minutos de
análisis de estas consecuencias del vbr
existe en la práctica algo que marca el
inicio de este año 2021 muchísimas
gracias luis rivas vélez arrunátegui
nani a nuestro corresponsal en londres
juan carlos bejarano ya todos ustedes
nos encontramos aquí de nuevo la próxima
semana en primera plana gracias
ah